This pandemic has really changed everything...
-But not for us!
We built a big dome over the f--king mansion!
What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
-They say form is temporary and class is permanent.
I hope they’re right, because my form has been...not good.
-Sometimes I like to pretend I’m Cinderella.
It fits!
-Terrible things are happening at Barcelona right now.
You hate to see it.
Me? I love to see it.
-Hi. I hope this message finds you well.
Just a gentle reminder that I still exist and would like a job.
-So far, life in The Dome is pretty good.
Every day, us cool, young bros make crazy pool parties,
the Farmers’ League is teaching us to grow our own food.
and anything else we need is delivered by drone!
[Shouting]
-Give it to Kevin!
-Oh, no! My scrunchies were in there!
-Our toothpaste!
-My brass knuckles polish!
-Whoa, whoa! What's the problem, lads?
-Allow me to interpret.
Our delivery box has crashed into the cornfield.
Now we are all without our luxury items.
And as a direct result, people are losing their s--t!
-A high-stakes rescue mission? That is O.F.T.
Opportunity for TikTok.
C'mon, bro, you're always on TikTok.
Cos I'm the king of TikTok.
[Groans]
[Cheers]
Don’t worry, guys.
The Champions will handle this.
[Chants]
-Eins, zwei, drei, Search Party!
-Let's do this for Canada,
I mean Drake,
I mean Germany.
-Hey, don't forget your fifth wheel, my dudes!
-It's not that we don't like Lewandowski.
I mean, on the pitch, he’s amazing.
But off the pitch?
Can't he just hang out with players his own age?
-Isn't this so lit?
Just a bunch of cool, young dudes having a cornfield and chill?
Hey, guys, what am I?!
What am I?
I'm a Pole dance!
[Grunts]
[Chuckles]
You get it? Pole dance...
Because I'm Polish.
-Yeah! We get it!
-Yo! Trill out, man!
-OK!
Everybody calm down.
You calm down!
Both of you Alphonsos need to back off, right now!
-Uh
hey, guys?
I think I found the box.
-Oh, s--t! We did it!
C'mon, guys, let's celebrate with a TikTok.
What's up, y'all?
We just did a search and rescue for this delivery box.
Cos if you want a job done,
you send in the Champions.
[Cheers]
-We will never die!
-What is wrong with you?!
-Yo, my phone won't turn on.
Mine either.
-Sacre bleu!
How are we to get home without our phones?
-What is your deal, dummkopf?
Why would you blast us with Champagne?
-Why did you even come along?
-It's time to face the facts.
I may only be 32 years young,
but I am also 32 years old.
Sorry, guys. I now realize I was being mad extra.
From now on, I’ll just be normal Robert.
Let's get you boys home.
Ah. Yes, that is poop.
Oh, look! We made it!
Or rather, I finished for you guys.
-Whoa! You did it!
How did you know to do all that stuff?
-This is how we got around in my day.
Before smartphones and Fitbits.
[Gasps]
-The ancient times.
-Man, old people are cool.
For once, we agree.
[Chuckles]
[Groans]
[Shouting]
-Seriously?
We’ve been gone 90 minutes.
What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
I’m so excited to make a big difference at Bayern…
maybe this season we can beat Barca 9-2.
-It took a bribery scandal to get Harry Maguire on the front page.
Me? All it took was a haircut.
-I never cheated on my Italian citizenship test.
PRODUCER: Are you reading that off a paper?
-No!
-(Grunts)
-Well, that's a bit odd.
-Everyone's been curious about my incredible man management
of Christian Pulisic.
Well, I kind of told him a lie...
as a form of motivation! Haha but no, I'm definitely manipulating him.
Ok, ok...I told Christian if he played really well this season
I could maybe get him a job in the Queen's Secret Service.
-What?! Why would you do this?
-Beg your pardon. Forgot to knock.
Being a secret agent is totally awesome.
I get to do one-liners and climb around in the air vent, plus,
Chelsea has so much money to burn,
they bought me, like, all these cool new gadgets!
Haha!
-Alright lads, everybody on the coach!
-Spy! Take the mask off!
-Get off me!
-What did you do with Frank?!
-Stop it!
Oh, that is you. Hey, Frank!
-I fear Christian’s taken the spy bit a bit too far.
If I’m to get him back onside, I’ll have to call in the big guns.
Hello, Jose. No, sorry, no time to talk right now.
Um, may I have Zlatan's number, please?
-Yeah, boy.
Pulisic. Christian, Pulisic.
Huh?
Zlatan?
(Gasp) Ibrahimovic!!!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Zlatan! I got your note about the secret mission!
-Shhh. Be cool, be cool.
Ok, here is the stupid backstory:
Someone is kidnapping footballers and turning them into...
human trophies!!
-(Gasp) Oh my god.
-There he is! Grab him!
-I've said too much! Run!
-Hey! Leave him alone!
We were in the middle of a conversation!
-Ooo, fresh meat!
-How bout a taste of this Hershey CHOPlet!
-Don't bother following us, Christian.
You'll never find us at our evil lair
located on Roman Abramovich's yacht,
which is the only boat in the harbor, 100 meters that way.
-Dang it, they got away!
Gosh. Now I’ll never find their evil lair.
Hmmm, where could it possibly be?
-The boat! They’re on the boat, man.
-I bet they’re on the boat.
-(Yelling)
Oh wow, the Zlatan statue.
They must have fixed it.
Nose is a little small, though.
-No, I've been turned into a trophy, you idiot!
-Shh, trophies don't talk.
-(Laughing)
-Congratulations, ding-dong.
You found me.
-Sergio Ramos?!
-Who else?
No, seriously, who else would be the bad guy?
-I'm gonna stop you!
-Well, you can either stop me
or save your friends!
-Please, save us.
-Yes, we are so scared.
-The choice is yours, Mr. Pulisic!
-Hmmm. My friends? Or Sergio Ramos?
My friends? Or Sergio Ramos?
My friend-
-Bruv! You can do both, just get a move on.
-Right!
Hang in there, chaps.
I'll get you down!
-Wait, don't-
-Gee. Thanks, Christian. You saved us.
-Hasta la vista, baby!
Your Majesty?
-Oh, gasp! Save me, Mr. Pulisic!
-Let the Queen go, Sergio Ramos!
-(Shouting)
-Alright, alright! I'm going, jeez.
What an overreaction, this guy.
-Oh! Thank you, Agent 10.
You really gave it 110 percent.
Terrific, a proper spy job.
But that must have been very stressful and overwhelming.
Hmmm?
Enough to make you never want to be a spy again?
-Are you kidding? I'm just getting started.
C'mon, give me another mission!
Give me another mission!
Anything! Anything!
-I now realize my lie has sent Christian
down a dangerous path of self-delusion.
Welp, there's only one way to sort this:
with an even bigger lie.
Alright, one more mission.
I need you to go undercover as a Chelsea footballer.
So deep under cover that you'll never speak
of being a spy ever again.
Ever. Got it?
-Oohhh that is so smart!
I mean, I don't get it at all,
but it sounds really smart.
-There must've been an easier way to do this.
-Last one to training’s a rotten egg!
-Hope there’s no lasers in there!
Right?
Please, Christian.
-Ha! Don't worry, that's all behind me.
I'm just a regular ole football player guy now.
-Splendid!
-Good show, Agent Pulisic.
You’ve made Britain proud.
And Frank doesn't suspect a thing.
-And he never will.
What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
-People say all I do is score penalties…
but I also dive to win those penalties.
-Oh, yeah! First American to wear the Barca jersey!
America!
-You think it’s so easy for Bayern to win the league?
It takes a lot of careful planning
to buy all the best players from all the other teams.
-When the weather gets colder, it’s a good time to reconsider Florida.
We’ve got loads of hot spots.
(Coughs)
-Hurry up, mate!
The ladies will be here any minute.
-Hello, lads, we brought you some lunch.
(Gasps)
What you doing?!
-Relax, bruv, we’re diggin’ a contraband tunnel.
-Jadon, if you want to play for Manchester United one day
you can't be breaking the rules all willy-nilly.
That’s how you end up slippin’.
- Slip on this.
(Farts)
-Eww, that's a stinker.
-(Laughing)
-That’s it. You need to learn some respect.
Right now you have it pretty good at the mansion,
but you never know what next season brings.
Time you see how the other half lives…
on a tour of Europa House.
-No! I can’t go back!
You can’t make me!
-Have a good ebening.
-Hello? Anyone here?
-Here's Vardy!
-Oi! Do not sneak up on people like that!
-Welcome to Europa House.
Sorry about the exploding light bulbs...
They're incandescent!
As a former juvenile delinquent,
I’ve developed a process for getting through
to young players and settin’ ‘em straight.
I just scare the s--t out of them.
Right this way, up-and-coming talents!
Let me be your ghoulish guide through this house of Meh.
We start every day here with a free breakfast buffet.
-Oh, that's not so bad.
-But it's also not so good,
because there's no eggs.
-(Yelling)
-Where do they get their protein?
-Here we have our all-inclusive community fitness center.
-Oh, nice.
-But it's just one elliptical!
-(Gasps)
-That’s not how you’re supposed to use that!
-Want to take a dip in our Stadio Olimpico-sized swimming pool?
Well, too bad, because there’s no towels!
-(Yelling)
-Oh, no, they’re cold!
-Check this out!
-(Shouting)
-(Screaming)
-Bloody hell!
-What happened to those guys?!
-Oh. Nothing, that's just their away kits.
I was tryna show you how small the rooms is.
-(Gasps)
-I don’t like it here. It’s scary.
-Pshhh. What’s scary? This guy?
Scariest thing about him is his caffeine addiction.
(Laughing)
-I'm sorry, you think I'm funny? I'm funny how?
I mean, funny like a clown?
I'm not a clown. This guy's a clown.
-I do birthday parties, Bar and Bat Mitzvahs,
Quinceaneras, and I've even done some football games.
-Look, mate, you can’t scare me, so stop trying.
It's just embarrassing.
-Oh, you don't think I'm scary?
Alright, then, I'll show you something scary.
-What is this place?
-It's a sauna...
But it never gets hot!
Go ahead, take a look-see.
-(Hissing)
-F--k me,
what was that?
-Anyone fancy a loan to Leicester?
-You know what...
-Oh, hell no
-I'm out
-Hell no
-I must not
-No, thank you
-Behold. My envelope of doom
shall reveal your fate.
Ah, Phil Foden. Hope of England,
like so many talents before you.
Till a little injury will become a persistent one.
And before you know it, your contract is up for renegotiation,
and you find yourself smiling through the pain
as you hold up a West Ham shirt.
-No!
I don’t like people blowing bubbles at me!
-Ansu Fati.
They call you the next Messi.
But like Bojan before you, it all goes wrong.
You ask for more playing time, but instead
you’re sold to a Portuguese club with a buy-back clause.
And you’re never bought back.
-(Screaming)
-OK, Brendan, I think that’s enough.
They're just young lads.
-And you,
Jadon Sancho.
Your fortune is just three letters long.
M... L... S...
-No!
-(Laughing)
-Please, please
-I'll be good. I promise.
-Call us an Uber back to the mansion,
-Oh, no!
-I hate it here.
-I said that's enough!
-(Yelling)
Mommy please!
-Phew!
Thanks, mate. You really showed me I need to shape up,
so I don’t end up like you.
-Ah! Another successful role-modeling by Jamie Vardy.
Bon voyage, lads!
Don’t forget to write to your new mentor, Jamie Vardy.
I’d come closer if it weren’t for me ankle bracelet!
What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
-Things are really crazy at Barcelona right now.
But I am not one to panic.
-Hey, did you call me?
-Every team needs an identity.
Mine is “Premier League: Where Are They Now.”
-People keep saying my problem is that I overthink things.
But have they considered that
they’re not thinking about things enough?
-Mmm! England is so different from Germany.
But at least the food is still bad!
-C’mon, microchip,
I know you’re in there somewhere.
Ever since leaving Liverpool,
people act like I just walked off
the edge of the flat Earth.
Ha!
But I am still the best defender...
of the truth.
You see that? The dome is fake.
It’s a projection created by Bill Gates to control us.
Exhibit A:
Yah-hoo!
(Grunts)
(Sniffs)
Oh.
What is this?
A smell like a Dutch meadow full of tulips?
(Sniffs)
Oh yeah.
Virgil?
You're supposed to be injured.
(Gasps)
This is impossible.
-Can I help you, Dejan?
-Oh, I'm so sorry…
I was, uhhh, looking for Mo Salah.
I miss him so bad.
-Cool.
Anyways, good luck with that.
-Hey, uh, you were running pretty fast in there, huh?
-I guess.
I mean, I'm just rehabbing.
-And you didn't even break a sweat.
-I never do.
-He can't be human.
He sprints with a bad ACL,
doesn't sweat
and still smells like a springtime in Holland?
There's something stinky going on.
And I'm gonna stick my nose in it.
-(Yelling)
-(Machines whirring)
Now, this is a very good string map.
(Gasps)
Clones.
-You shouldn't be here, Dejan.
-You were transferred.
-(Yelling)
You guys,
you're not gonna believe it!
Virgil van Dijk is a clone!
And there's a whole army of clones
in a secret Liverpool laboratory!
-A Livertory?
-Or is it like a Laborapool?
-Oh, come on, guys.
This is just another one of his
coo-coo-wackadoo theories.
-It's true! I can prove it!
-It’s always something with this guy.
First he said there’s a secret
fight club in the basement,
then Gareth Bale’s an alien, and now this?!
You are a liar, and nobody believes you.
And even if we did believe you,
nobody has a VHS player.
-He has a point.
-Right on point, Malcom is.
-Right.
-Yes, yes.
-Who has time to rewind things these days?
-Very right. Yes.
-Sorry, Dejan.
But maybe it's time to find a new hobby.
And a new hat.
-If I want to convince these guys,
I will need some hard evidence.
-(Glass breaks)
-This will do.
-That doesn't belong to you, Dejan.
-Get back! I’ll expose you!
I’ll tell the whole world what you’re doing here!
-You shouldn’t have said that.
-Now, we can’t let you leave.
-Flank him.
(Chanting)
-You’ll never walk alone.
(Group chanting)
-Wait, I didn’t mean it. I saw nothing!
-(Chanting)
-C’mon, who am I going to tell?!
-Nobody believes me anyway, right?
-(Chanting)
-OK.
-OK, I’ll never stick my nose
-(Chanting)
where it doesn’t belong again!
-Please! I didn't mean it!
-(Chanting)
-No!
-(Chewing)
-Woah, the eggs here are so good.
-Hello, comrades. It's me.
Dejan Lovren.
The Zenit Saint Petersburg
centre-back No. 6!
After a good night's sleep,
I now realize
there's no such thing as clones.
Anyways, enjoy your day!
-Uh… Did anyone else notice
Lovren has no belly button?
-Yeah.
He's a weirdo.
Cleaning up after everyone is exhausting.
I really need a holiday.
When booking my trip,
I sometimes wonder...
What else could possibly go wrong?
I mean, that probably won't happen.
But if my plans have to change,
it doesn't matter.
Because Hotels.com has flexible booking options.
Hotels.com. Because just in case.
What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
-Watch out!
Santa Klopp is coming to town!
-I like my candy canes Harry.
-Hmmm. I suppose I should ask Santa for a real passport.
-What gift can you give a man who has it all?
-Uh, humility?
-Oh, how much is that? I’ll buy 100 humilities.
-It’s a holly jolly lolly golly Christmas Day!
-Ding dong ding dong
-Fa la la la la la la la!
-Shoo! Shoo! Get out of here, Europa House urchins!
Ew.
Ooo, ooh.
I love Cristiano-mas.
It's a time to put aside our differences
and receive expensive gifts.
Oooo! What is this? It's a squishy trophy.
Is it, uh,
(sniffs)
is it supposed to smell like this?
-All right, all right, this one is for you, Robert.
-Oh cool, my dudes, you should not have!
Wow, it’s so big! It must be a-
a Ballon d'Or?
-Well, we figured you deserved it this year anyway and-
-Oh, wait wait wait. Hold on, hold on.
Who are you to just give someone the Ballon d'Or?
-I mean, he was the top scorer in the Bundesliga
and the Champions League this year
and Bayern won the treble so-
-OK, well if we're all just giving the awards to our teammates,
uh, Ronaldo! For, uh, having the most Instagram followers,
you get the Ballon d'Or. Here.
-No! Messi gets the Ballon d'Or
for putting up with Bartomeu.
-(Grunting)
-Give me that.
-Give it back you-
-Well, if we’re giving out the Ballon d'Or,
I want the Lev Yashin Award for best goalkeeper!
-Oh, like you would win!
-I want a Grammy!
-I want the Nobel Peace Prize, man!
-Oh, fart you!
-(Shouting)
-(Whistle blow)
-Here’s how we will settle this.
We will all get dressed up and gather in the auditorium
and I will host this year's Ballon d’Or.
It will be a very tasteful ceremony
as long as everybody follows my rules.
OK?
Here are the rules!
Nine men enter!
One man leaves!
BEGIN!
-(Shouting)
-Who run Barca-town?!
-Wait. I don't get it,
what are the teams?
-I am very confused!
-Should half of us take our shirts off or something?
-Why did you call it Beyond Ballon D'ome
when all the important stuff happens
inside the Ballon D'ome?
-Yeah, I guess I got carried away
with all the cool costumes and production design
and didn’t really think the rest of this concept through.
OK, OK, new rules.
How 'bout this:
Four men enter.
Two men leave.
Those men advance to the knockout round.
We do this eight times.
Then we take those 16 men
and put their names in a pot-
-Hey look! It's snowing!
-Woah, snowflakes.
-Snow.
-Oh, it makes me so happy.
I love the snow.
It's a white Christmas.
-I hate to be the interpreter of bad news,
but that is just asbestos from the roof.
-Oh no.
-Awww.
-Not snow?
-Now I'm sad.
-Dang it.
-Guys, what are we doing?
It's Christmas.
We shouldn't be fighting over some award,
we should be coming together.
-Kevin.
-Kevin's right.
Robert, if anyone deserves the Ballon d'Or,
it's you, man.
You earned it.
-Thank you, guys, that means a lot.
And while I 100 percent deserve the award,
2020 has been hard on everybody.
So how about this year we all share da Ballon d'Or?
-(Cheering)
-Christmas! Christmas!
-Gifts! Gifts!
-Oh yeah!
--Everybody's a GOAT!
-The Christmas spirit. I love it!
-(Clears throat)
-VAR bless us, everyone.
-Ho Ho
(Yelling)
-I need a break after being stuck here forever
doing other people's laundry.
When booking my trip, I sometimes wonder,
"What else could possibly go wrong?"
I mean, that probably won't happen.
But if my plans have to change
it doesn't matter
because Hotels.com has flexible booking options.
Hotels.com.
Because just in case.
Nom, nom, nom!
For more corny videos,
like and subscribe to B/R Football.
If only I had teeth!